welcome back to grammar and filtered
faces by me Josh Smith and today we are
joined by the Emmy award-winning you
always give the best thing truth I mean
you've got the CV for the intro to I
mean she's got Racine yes we are hips
ain't about talking heads which is this
amazing new series that's coming to BBC
I've seen it and let's get real it's
like a 45 minute tour de force in acting
from you
it was so hard like I remember finishing
the day and being like that is without a
doubt the most difficult thing I've ever
done so it's something I definitely feel
proud of I also love the fact that you
that's the most difficult thing you've
done and then most people on screen
would be like so murdering X number of
people wasn't the most difficult thing
or like you know wise it was the
concentration and I think there was like
20 pages of dialogue and and obviously
we shot it within the lockdown role new
rules and regulations less people on set
it was like one of the person on set
with me at any given time so the set was
deadly deadly silence all the things I
loved about this is this character
Leslie who you play she's kind of this
actress who has got wild ambition she
wants to be the top of her game possibly
finding it very tough to get snap I'm
just wondering like throughout your
career has there been a time when you
felt like something was gonna be your
big break
and you were like this is it honeys and
then it didn't happen and then how did
you deal with that I feel like they all
make up to that big big break I mean
obviously killin eve was was huge I'm
always I think I'm more of a pessimist
I'm always a bit like oh no one's you
know oh God you know you you worry more
I think than going well this is it guys
I've made it it's more like oh my god
like I was gonna hate it that I'm never
gonna work again my
I mean of course like you do things and
they you put so much into them and not
everything runs well you know it's not
like every everything you do is a
roaring success and that's okay and I
think as long as you go into something
with integrity you know the reasons
you're doing it and why you believe in
it it doesn't matter if it if it's a bit
of a flock because you you justify your
convictions and you believe in it and
then it never really matters whereas I
think if you get into something for the
wrong reasons and then it doesn't go
well then then you've got to answer to
yourself because I think that idea of
having how to be authentic is such
discussion right now being an authentic
person being attentive actress doing the
right things making the right decisions
for you but I guess as well like you
also have this South critic that's like
sat here all the time how do you what is
your relationship with your south critic
lie
you know I'm better with dealing with
that kind of critique of myself like
because I feel I feel confident in what
I do and and I believe in what I do and
I I kind of trust my strengths whereas
if it's something more personable like
your self-esteem or you know what people
think of you will reading things online
that aren't true well though cut those
kinds of things it's harder for me to UM
kind of put my big girl pants on and be
like no also depends on the time of the
month Josh we're always gonna criticize
ourselves in different ways right like
there's always new time you feel like oh
my god I'm not I'm not being that
positive edge there I'm not giving
enough today I'm not giving I think it's
almost like we always have to stop
apologizing for ourselves right I think
especially I think people are more
accepting of that now as we're all kind
of going through the same thing but are
separated where it's been a time when
you've literally in your career possibly
not have that self belief and you picked
yourself up and you've been like Jody
get this to get that for me now is a
little bit different but like
you might go to 30 auditions 40
auditions before you get a yes so
actually you're constantly having to
pick yourself back up you know you go to
you go to an audition on the Monday you
don't hear anything you go to a
different edition on the Thursday
the following Monday oh you didn't get
that and you didn't get this one okay
like milena not to take it personally
and then go into your next meeting and
not carrying that with you and I and I
think or whenever I got not gotta roll
and watch the thing that I auditioned
for and like ah see why I didn't get it
you know but then it's it's so easy to
go oh god was it the way I looked was
that my acting was it too much was it
you know it's um so I think the key is
to try and not take it personally yeah
you're not always gonna be someone's
copper to you that they like a milky tea
sometimes I like it with one should go I
mean I don't want to be someone's milky
tea thank you make peace with it but
like I think as well with that there's
an Lesley in the character in talking
heads as she put so much pressure on
herself and like so much like over the
way she looks so the way she doesn't
scene over the way she's gonna achieve
things like how much pressure and what
kinds of pressure did you put on
yourself at the beginning that you don't
necessarily put in yourself now oh god I
think the the notion of like you know
wanting everyone to think I'm great all
good at what I do
um or the expectation to say the right
thing and I think is why I'm getting
much much better ah and because
obviously when you come into it you're
like you're an open book and and and
you're so eager to please and then the
more you go on you're like oh it's it's
not the way the world works
and and I'm definitely by no means there
and I don't think you ever will be but
I'm definitely more better I going okay
it's months opinion and that's not going
to affect my choices or what I do next
or you know that kind of thing um so I
guess just trying to keep a strong head
strong head about you doing there's more
respect in that sense for your voice as
well you always have to prove people
wrong gore you know people are like that
was really good or Wow and you're like
yeah I did a theater play when I was
like 16 but I got the part yet I was
going with you audition and the
character was middle class RP very
well-spoken very wealthy family and and
I got there and it was obviously must
have been the only scouser order and
definitely girl from the north northwest
of England it wasn't until I got the
part that the director that had told me
that before I went in she was like why
why have we brought her in for the
audition because she seemed whereas prom
and she didn't she didn't and she didn't
think I was capable and I got it yes
when she told me I was like wow and
that's another thing I think is really
interesting because you just never know
what's going on the other side of that
door because I was from Liverpool she
didn't think I could do it could do and
happy accent but that's kind of just so
annoying because that's also like we're
talking like that's so class this as
well isn't it it's like Oh completely so
much it so many meetings are like you
can you lose that yes time here for me
because it's so strong but I think it
definitely is a classist thing and I
think it's something that is like is
ingrained in you without you even know
and like that Steven gray and like I
always thought we mean Steven I talked
about it before it's like this
and past the syndrome of like because of
where you're from you feel so lucky to
be where your are and it's like well
actually no you have as much you know
right to be there as anybody else with
with any other or the kind of background
having also with this this 45 minutes of
this show where it's all about she
touches a lot of my audition process and
what she's been through and the trials
and tribulations of that for you
personally can you remember a time when
you've done an audition you've been like
this is the absolute pits like this like
this is this is the worst of the worst
moments for me or a time when it's
messed up and you've been so desperate
for it to happen I remember it from my
where we work when I was with my old
agency I was I got a train to London to
do an audition for a economy was but it
was some sort of thing it's a production
that had dance in it and my train got
delayed and I was like probably 45
minutes late to this audition and when I
got there it was like a dance workshop
and there was already like 30 girls in
the room learning the choreography you
know like very kind of feign chorus line
ask walk then with my bag like sweat
dripping off me and they were like just
just go to the back and and kind of
follow follow the routine and then of
course they bug bring you to the front
in groups of four to better show the
worst thing is I must have been about I
was with my old agency so I must have
been about 15 16 at the time of course
it's wonderful to be in a position where
like if people have material they're
like would you like to do this or we're
thinking of you like that's them you
know that's always where you you aim to
be but I think there is something about
going into an audition room knowing all
of your business and then having the
confidence of going I understand this
character this is how I feel this is
where you just fly yeah well you can
also know that you you've understood
there and you're on the right you're on
the right track whereas of course if you
if you got offered something it's like
that well the first time you're gonna
actually do a scene it's probably on day
one if you don't have rehearsals and
then you're like what if they like oh my
god we've cast the wrong girl
insecurities like you say it's like that
little voice in your head that it's
constantly thinking that something
something's gonna be kind of swept from
one beefy or you know do you still feel
like that yeah yeah I don't think that
goes away and I kind of hope it doesn't
like I would never want to be I would
never want to get to a point where I
feel settled and because actually I
think one of my driving forces is being
scared to do something because I think
then you know that you're challenging
yourself and then you're only gonna grow
from that cuz I guess that shows there's
so much power in this idea of leaning
into your insecurities right have you
learned for me that it that is acting
like you you put so much of yourself out
there all of your vulnerabilities mm and
actually I think that can be quite
cathartic you know like some days you
know you might have a big kind of
emotional day on set and yeah some
things you might go home absolutely
exhausted but then it's kind of like a
weird release it's kind of like free
therapy isn't it like I'm just gonna let
out all this weird emotions going on my
head right now I'm just gonna into this
character she can deal with it and I can
leave her alone cold-cut and then like
for a minute I feel like are you okay
you're like yeah but I think like
emotions just fascinate me like and of
course that's what we deal with when
you're when you're acting so I think
it's a good message to say to people
there is actually power to be found in
your vulnerability oh my god absolutely
completely I mean because we all are
vulnerable and all in little ways and I
think that when you know when someone
when you feel confident comfortable
enough space to open up and someone else
those like that connection is so
lovely like I feel like it only draws
you closer to people and I guess this
like social media like everything's
great you know no problems here we we
lose that ability to kind of connect
with each other do you feel like there's
you've tried to like safeguard your
identity in yourself that you don't get
overwhelmed by this crazy situation
you've been placed in like my family and
my friends would put me in my place
you're like like off the bat and I've
made peace with this like this is the
career I chose this is the job that I
love to do like but there is so little
about this kind of career this life that
you have control of one of the stories
when we spoke last time you told me
which I just loved so much is when we're
talking about when you have your like
hangover ships and Tesco's and you're
like loving life on those checkout slash
not living like this chunk out if you
were a customer shimming up to that girl
at the checkout and you could give her
one piece of advice what would you want
to give that girl at the checkout I've
always had such a strong idea of of what
I want to do and what I don't want to do
and don't get me wrong sometimes I've
you know especially as you know things
get much bigger it's so easy to kind of
get swamped up in it all and kind of get
a little bit off track well I think it's
just yeah keep doing what you're doing
and you know I also had like when I when
I was like young and you know doing
drugs here and there like I'd have
people say to me like well like a like
you think you're gonna be in films like
what you're gonna do if that doesn't
play house and I'm like not gonna like
kind of think about like that's not
gonna happen
you know and so when I think back to
that response I'm like like do and have
that go in the back yeah
but maybe not the gala which I really
like maybe don't go out three nights on
the weekend a little bit more sleep
would probably be the advice actually
well I think if the gal in the checkout
knew you were gonna end up in the last
jewel with Matt day yeah maybe like whoa
maybe like this guy
well datable it's been amazing speaking
to you as a way it's like the best